dans l'année qui a suivi les manifestations de Gezi.
Oui, les gouvernements ont différentes ressources à apporter
ce n'est donc pas pareil, mais les différences sont instructives.
Comme pour toutes ces histoires, il ne s'agit pas juste de technologie,
mais bien de ce qu'elle nous aide à accomplir et réaliser.
Les mouvements sociaux d'aujourd'hui veulent opérer de manière informelle.
ils ne veulent pas d'encadrement institutionel.
Ils ne veulent pas se mêler de politique par peur de corruption et cooptation.
Et ils n'ont pas tort.
De puissants intérêts font taire les agents de la démocratie moderne
dans de nombreux pays.
Mais de cette manière il leur est difficile
de durer dans le temps et d'influencer le système,
ce qui cause l'amenuisement des protestataires,
et encore plus de corruption en politique.
La politique et la démocratie sont bancales sans un recours efficace,
parce que les causes qui ont inspiré les mouvements modernes sont cruciales.
Le réchauffement climatique nous guette.
Les inégalités étouffent la croissance humaine, notre potentiel, l'économie...
L'autoritarisme étouffe de nombreux pays.
Il faut que ces mouvements soient plus efficaces.
Certains avancent que que le problème
est qu'on ne prend pas autant de risques qu'avant.
Et ce n'est simplement pas vrai.
A Gezi, à Tahrir et ailleurs,
j'ai vu des gens mettre leur vie en danger.
Malcolm Gladwell a tort de dire que les manifestants d'aujourd'hui
ont des liens virtuels moins solides.
Non, ils viennent à ces manifestations, tout comme avant,
avec leurs amis, leur réseau,
et parfois ils forment de nouvelles amitiés à vie.
Je revois encore les amis
que je me suis faits lors des manifestations zapatistes il y a dix ans.
Et les liens entre inconnus ne sont pas sans valeur.
Quand j'ai reçu du gaz lacrymogène à Gezi, des inconnus m'ont aidée.
Tout le monde s'entraidait au lieu de s'enfuir.
À Tahrir, j'ai vu des gens, des protestataires,
travailler vraiment dur pour se protéger les uns les autres.
Et sensibiliser au numérique est génial
parce qu'on change la politique en changeant les perceptions.
Mais les mouvements contemporains
doivent rapidement passer outre le taux de participation,
et trouver un moyen de penser ensemble comme une collectivité,
de développer de fortes propositions politiques, créer un consensus,
de déterminer les étapes politiques, et de les comprendre pour avoir du poids,
parce que toutes ces bonnes intentions, ce courage et ces sacrifices
ne seront pas assez.
Il y a beaucoup d'efforts.
En Nouvelle-Zélande, un groupe de jeunes développe une plateforme appelée Loomio
pour la prise de décision participative à une certaine échelle.
En Turquie, 140 Journos conduisent un hackathon
pour apporter du soutien aux communautés et au journalisme citoyen.
En Argentine, une plateforme open-source du nom de DemocracyOS
encourage la participation au parlement et aux partis politiques.
Tout ceci est génial et il nous en faut plus.
Mais il nous faut plus qu'un meilleur processus décisionnel en ligne.
Pour actualiser la démocratie, il nous faudra innover à tous les niveaux.
De l'organisationnel au politique, au social.
Car pour obtenir un succès à long terme,
parfois, il est bon de prendre du thé sans sucre,
pour accompagner nos Tweets.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)